okay good morning Chris Harrison you
have just revealed the women how many
flight attendants did we have three four
twelve fourteen so what do you think you
could tell the audience the odds are
that Peter ends up with a flight
attendant his parents did that right Ovi
what's it like 17 17 between 17 23 % he
ends up with the flight attendant no
agenda that's the Vegas odds Harris has
that on the board well then that is
that's and people have to remember that
that's how a Peters parents met his
parents are definitely his life goals
his love goals they're definitely a big
part of this season as well and so hey
could history repeat itself could end up
with a flight attendant and so much
opportunity for so many aviation jokes
yeah I'm just gonna come gonna apologize
to you and everyone else right now
aviation windmill you name it it's there
we're gonna lean into it a little bit
this pilot thing's gonna fly itself on
out I am so excited
I have no idea what's coming but I know
that my life
okay yeah we couldn't we're gonna find
Peter in the cockpit Oh see that's a guy
can also a lot of pageants ladies yeah
so we know one pageant ladies coming
back Hannah brown and does she know some
of these other pageant women is there
drama with girls she might know from the
past
it's no there's not really drama
from-from Hannah's life to this one it's
not like a Kailyn spill over so it's not
that they all know each other it's just
but yeah we're still I guess leaning
also into this pageant world that we've
kind of delved into with Kailyn and and
Hannah from last season and there are
girls that do know each other from the
pageant world but it's not a Hannah
crossover but that would have been a
good note we should have done that
how much does Hannah cause drama or
bring something into this season we've
seen the clips and her and Peter seem to
have this palpable chemistry but every
time I've interviewed Hannah lately for
a little show called Dancing with the
Stars she's very adamant about I was
filming Dancing with the Stars yeah she
was not filming Dancing with the Stars
well she was I mean she wanted but she
also was appearing on how much is she on
the show and clearly you saw her on the
show like right and so I think you will
see her make a pretty big impression on
the show look in all seriousness her and
Peter they just they just have this
thing that intangible kind of chemistry
and it's one of those things that no
matter how much you think you're over
somebody when you see each other it's a
thing it's still a thing and it's not to
say you know look is he over her is she
over him I'm not gonna get into that
I'll let them deal with that on the show
but it's a thing and there is some
serious chemistry between the two that's
just undeniable and that's why we wanted
to have her back on the show it's not
just a hey I'm here to hit you on the
shoulder and say good luck
okay it's more than that did they kiss
it's no I won't sell just say it's more
than that it's not more than the kissing
what I meant was it's more than just a
hey buddy good luck more than a
handshake yes okay so you know in the
bachelor lexicon we were kind of looking
back at how things will be remembered
Colton's season virginity and a fence
jump colton cultist
you just jumped up fence
Hannah season empowerment in a windmill
this is my first fantasies we all
nervous I don't have any expectations
but intimacy is really important to me
in something that I hold dear in my
heart
it's important to have those moments
where I can be like my body is your body
my heart is your heart my soul like we
are completely entangled in every single
way
what is Peter season wow those are
amazing tag lines do sir I don't but
honestly the thing is you don't know yet
because you know we knew the fence jump
was gonna be a big deal but it that the
fact that it became such a thing and in
Hannah saying you know we did it four
times in a windmill and Jesus still
loves me you know you don't know those
things are gonna happen you don't know
they're really gonna be such a focal
point of the show so I'm not sure what
it's gonna be with Peter obviously that
the gash across the face will be a thing
hopefully that's not all he's known for
but that's good that'll be a moment this
season that happens a little bit into it
it's obviously while we're traveling so
we have to get out of LA because it
happens on our second stop while we're
traveling I don't think that'll become a
centerpiece but it'll be a story how
much does it affect things because does
it affect like what dates he can do or
how much he has to take care of it
that's just the cut you know it's funny
were talking about this it should have
affected the show more than it did and I
mean that in that we were probably not
great at helping him take care of it as
much we probably should have been better
but he's such a gamer and this is why I
love Peter he immediately was apologetic
about doing it and felt so bad that he
had messed up the show and ruined our
lives and ruined the franchise and so he
I think probably before he should have
was diving into waterfalls and pools of
water and things when it probably should
so he was he's such a sweet sincere
loving guy that just he's a team player
and he wanted to help us out so okay
well Hannah season will also be
remembered for the JED girlfriend
scandal yeah do we get a bigger more
dramatic scandal this season how does it
up the ante there's there's a I mean
this mean
to say there's a lot of drama but there
is a lot of drama this season and it
involves several of the women there's a
lot of layers and they mention Victoria
you said she goes through anything and
everything she goes through everything
how much everything that's ever happened
ever on the show it's happened and then
made up stuff she there's a lot of
firsts with her and and it says she's
just a part of a wild ride and it's some
of it is is self-induced some of it just
happens to her is she a villain yeah
maybe yeah probably ends up that way I
don't know if she's the season villain
but I think she ends up as one yeah I
don't know if you saw she posted on
Instagram this big thing about don't
believe the rumors you're gonna have to
see it off yeah well let it play out and
that's why I mean I guess it's hard to
pin or is quote-unquote the villain
because there's a lot of layers a lot of
interesting dramatic layers to this
season with a lot of these women I got
to go back to Hannah for a second so you
quick rapid-fire questions one could
Hannah ever be the Bachelorette again
sure why not yeah I mean I love Hannah
she's one of my favorites obviously she
has a lot of heat and momentum after
that Mirrorball thing she just did do
you think her and Tyler should be
together some fans still want that I
think if she was ever the bachelor I
think it'd be fun if he showed up I
don't know I don't know and I'm speaking
to Bowie out of school I don't know him
well enough to know what his life is
like anymore don't know what's going on
but if he's still single and she's still
single stunningly attractive couple
there you go all right a fantasy suites
rapid-fire this is pilot Pete what's up
in the air how many times is windmill
said per episode though I would say I
don't know I would set the over-under at
seven okay how does Pete top his
windmill fantasy suite a cave a plane I
was gonna say five times Oh does he
because he was four times effort now
it's five really reference from night
one Wow okay Peter told me before the
season began that he was not a member of
the mile-high club does he become one
mmm someone might be carrying that card
now Pete kept flying right he continued
being a pilot as he filled how many
times does he enter the cockpit Peter
after you you see Peter enters the
cockpit
you're not doing real math 4 times oh I
see what you were doing there ok
yep I'm crying does he continue to fly
does he keep flying as a pilot while you
were filming Oh was he
commercially fly oh no no he took time
off to shoot the show and actually you
know got some help filling it around but
he didn't step away from his airline and
he's back he's already back flying
commercially yeah and actually I cuz I
talked to Peter obviously quite a bit
because we're neighbors back again and
he was just excited to be back and
flying again and in back with the
airline and probably because that's
where he gets some solace and quiet and
yeah alright well how do things end up
repeat did you imagine her flying and
like hey everybody its bachelor Peter I
think he should we're headed to
Cincinnati and make sure to catch the
show tonight on ABC why didn't you guys
do a deal with Delta guess who dropped
the ball
Delta nice epic fail so he way to not be
a part of it how would you not how would
you not lean into that I don't know yeah
nice a sponsorship we know East whiff
how do things end up for people well
he's married she's pregnant
great yeah that spoiler alert spoiler
along no it's it's a while I will say
this and I don't mean this as a pilot
reference or anything it's a wild ride
for Peter it is a very wild ride I was
trying to think of a season I could go
back and reference kind of like a Ben
Higgins type of season where it's a guy
who really wears his heart in his
emotions on his sleeve and is really
good at compartmentalizing but almost
too much so that he really Linz he has a
tough time kind of just like you know
cutting the cord with people and things
kind of linger and stuff and that makes
it difficult as he kind of kicks the can
down the road you meet some emotional
roadblocks and things get pretty tough
down the road
he and I have some heart-to-hearts okay
I feel like his emotions spill over yeah
[Music]